there's something happened this last
week that is deeply concerning i'm
wondering like as a
well-trained cia agent how would you
solve this mystery because
it's it's it's heavy on my heart so an
alleged stoner stopped after wild card
chase whips out
license from legoland okay
a uk driver who was arrested for
reckless driving had officers and
stitches after producing
a license from legoland the driver was
pursued from br bexley
to uh isle of a sheppy and arrested for
multitude of offenses last week
according to a tweet by kent police rpu
which apprehended the 21 year old
motorist in february following an epic
car chase
this was a 35 mile car chase and this
guy when he gets pulled over he takes
out his lego is this truly a real story
or what tell me you're joking with me no
it's legit and you get the license
there's a driving lego land and it's got
like a speed cam
a few other things and you get this
license and here it is right here i've
seen i've actually seen this lego land i
took i took my daughter to that lego
land and it's true they you can get a
driver's license and yeah so the guy had
a big bag of weed
um
he's uh as far as i'm concerned he's a
hero um
i think it's a fantastic story and
great news right it does i think it says
more about the poor kent police because
the average highway patrol in any of the
50 states would be far less patient than
35 miles
you would have put you to put the trip
line down
pop the tires or catch up behind them
give them a spin
we just have you have patrolling
have you ever gone to the airport and
you forgot your idea or passport has
that ever happened to you
have you ever gone to the airport to
travel you forget yourself i feel like
you have a story behind it i'm just
curious because this happened to me
multiple times i'm asking you if it's
happened to you
i'm sure it's never happened to you
actually it's never happened but it's
happened to you yeah i thought i showed
up and i realized all of a sudden i
didn't have a passport now to be fair i
was traveling to canada i guess i just
thought that was another state and so i
didn't think they'd actually want my
passport uh one time i went to the wrong
uh one time i went to the wrong airport
um i was heading back overseas
that this guy was right
now i was hungover uh i was i was back
in the states for just a few days got
together with some guys that were back
here this was when i was in the old job
and uh we went out and
might have had a little bit too much to
drink i had to go overseas to do
something and uh went to uh instead of
going to dulles airport in washington i
went to national and you know
bounced around there for a while trying
to figure out where the hell is my
flight you know it's getting really
shirty with the the gay people and
saying no but i'm flying i'm leaving
here to go and they said and they looked
it up and they go no you're supposed to
be a driver oh i love when yeah it's so
funny in dallas it would happen all the
time you're online the guy's like sir
your flight's from love field not from
dfw you're kidding me no you have to
leave okay
what happened to me one time is we
parked the car in dfw but morale booked
my flight back to love i totally forgot
about it and i'm like trying to go to
valley can you get my car i've been
waiting 20 minutes like sir we don't
have your car i'll call romero's like
your car is a dfw
yeah but it's always a fun conversation
when you're saying i'm telling you i'm
patrick that david sir
whatever do you have an id no what would
you like me to show you and you have to
make phone calls to get that part done
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you